well it's the day of the zero waste
challenge i'm probably the most
competitive out of three of us and i
really want to win
i ordered something on amazon more
weight
of all the plastic ever created only
nine percent has
actually been recycled i've been making
some efforts in my life to go
zero waste my lovely green grocer still
does the kale like that and it's like
well my health is one thing and the
the earth's health is the other doing
zero waste for one day
probably easier with just me but it's
got me my
lovely partner man and millie and my two
beautiful children the key thing really
is
making a bit more effort hello there my
name is captain robert
sheehan esquire hello there my name is
thomas hoppers hey there i'm byron
knight and i'm one of the triumvirative
hosts
of the earth locker podcast we dive into
discovering what makes us better
earthlings
seems like you guys are kind of already
interested in this but just to break it
down zero waste basically just means
trying to send as little as possible to
landfill
and it actually started as a waste
management term i think all of you are
mostly based in london
and i went ahead and i looked at your
mayor's environmental strategy
london aims to be zero waste by 2026.
did not know that
yeah so what do you guys say do you want
to get into looking at your trash
so organic stuff that's great you can
compost all that
greek yogurt take food lid
container thing there's tissues there's
lids
maybe do some meal prepping so then
you're not you know eating out
and using single-use plastics for your
yogurt
try to find either a glass
yogurt that you can purchase or you
could try making your own
coconut yogurt right now i'm in
quarantine
in canada so i find it tricky to be zero
waste so they'll come on these flow
waters i get drink probably like two to
three
the other thing i noticed as well it's
back home i would never know because i'm
using the cups from my own
house but it's these i get that
delivered see if there's a way you can
tackle your
coffee routine even if you just get
coffee grounds in a container
and you get your hands on a french press
or something and also
trying to eliminate your single-use
water i'm sitting next to my trash now
diapers
oh yeah i actually was too busy to have
lunch normally i would have gotten
takeaways somewhere
i see that you had some blueberries
perhaps
shopping trying to get some produce at
the farmers market
thank you guys for showing me your trash
you're already doing so well
i'm so excited for your 24 hours of no
trash and i am challenging you
to try and make as little trash as
possible and if you make any trash
i might you know spank you or spit on
you just kidding i only want to be your
cheerleader
but whoever i'm gonna make a ton of
trash though
you've done it now hello hello hello
this is how far i've come with my zero
waste
cosmetic routine which includes wiping
your bum
100 recycle no inks dies or scents
there's my shampoo and conditio no
plastic there
here's a little soap pouch for catching
the remnants of bits of soap
toothpaste in jar because all toothpaste
tubes
tend to end up in the landfill
unfortunately all of them
every single one that's ever been sold
here's some refilled
shampoo and conditi as well those are
reused bottles
there's a refill place near me where i
just refill my shampoos and conditioners
i'm doing my best you know doing my best
so i'm still
zero trash a couple of meals in had some
meat in a tupperware i'm
drinking my reusable water bottle from
the tap water
the only major difference really is
because i haven't got the water filter
yet here in quarantine
is the chlorine taste that you get from
tap water so
that's not ideal but filters are on the
way
charcoal filters which can go in these
how to get some
work gloves or some disposable gloves on
painting on a site and i thought okay
i'm not gonna get the disposal gloves i
want to get reusable gloves
and that way i don't have to throw away
and i'll use them a few times and it'll
be better
and then look my first fail of the day
for trash it came in a freaking plastic
bag
through the day trash free day god damn
it i ordered something on amazon
more waste but it is an eco-friendly
mattress topper
orianna threw down and she said i
challenge you to produce zero waste in
24 hours
as little trash as possible
then i was entertaining i had a couple
of friends coming over
so alas we made a mess i made
toast with sardines
and rocket and a bit of camembert so
i made a little bit of waste with like a
sardine tin and the wrapping around it
one thing that i found when we did the
uh the meet-up with
ori and the other guys is that i had way
more plasticky trash
so i'm determined to not have any
plastic waste today
i think i can do it because i've not had
a coffee this morning
not because i'm not addicted but because
i want to win but yeah so far
no trash okay so i'm on a zero waste
challenge today i don't want to make any
trash
i want no packaging so what i want
is some meat and takeaway containers
that's it looks good zero waste trip to
the butchers
look at that i avoided more trash
winning
[Music]
uh i failed the zero waste challenge
this time
it's an interesting thing to think about
you know how much plastic am i
into the environment daily on this zero
waste
challenge i think a big component of it
is self-compassion
trying to remove that voice in your head
that goes i must i must i must
i should i should i should and it's just
it's a combatant
and it ultimately compels you to do the
opposite of what you want to do
the last piece of meat that i had was
from this so i'm going to count this in
my 24 hours
so this is what happened today for a
family of four
definitely got a whammy because i'd
ordered something off amazon and arrived
today so
epic fail for me that's
my actual trash for the day i think i
kind of rocked today
good job completing the challenge i'm
proud of you
all for even attempting this in a
pandemic so pat yourselves all on the
back
zero waste is so difficult especially
during this time
and it's not about being perfect it's
just trying our best and you guys all
did that
if you guys could kind of guesstimate
how many
pieces of trash you each made what what
would you say
putting it generously i'd say 15 to 20.
but
they were bottles and paper you know i
opened a couple of things of sardines
my constant complaints about rocket you
know that it's wrapped in a plastic
suitcase
personally as an individual on the no
challenge i had one tissue paper
one plastic bag that my gloves came in
and at the end of the day i chose to
have a cider so i had a bottle of cider
but then as a family you know
no i don't think we did too bad it was
under 20 bits of waste that we produced
in a 24-hour period
amazingly i made actually no trash
like not here's here's the kicker though
i had
taken the meat out of the plastic when i
bought it two days previous
but within the 24 hour period yeah it
was only food waste i have
the average american makes 4.3 pounds of
trash a day
so you guys all did very well compared
to your
american counterparts and i think you're
all winners in my eyes but if we had to
declare one
i i think it's kind of a tie between
byron and tom
so thank you guys so much for doing this
and
how do we listen to your podcast the
earth locker it's on spotify apple
audioly and we have the youtube channel
as well thank you so much and thanks
buzzfeed for doing this with us
oh yeah thank you guys it's just so on
the point with what we're about you know
we're about making
ourselves better earthlings
[Music]
you